Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Je vous propose de nous interroger
ensemble sur la question suivante :
pourquoi les insectes ne sont-ils toujours
pas dans nos assiettes aujourd’hui ?
Je suis Laurent Veyet,
le fondateur du restaurant Inoveat.
En parallèle, je suis encore chef
à domicile et ça fait maintenant 25 ans.
Quand j’ai créé ma société,
Chef service, en 1996,
c’était très novateur pour l’époque parce
que ça n’avait jamais été fait auparavant.
Et j’avais - j’ai encore - un tempérament
très audacieux et très entreprenant
et j’ai eu l’idée d’envoyer des courriers
à différentes chaînes de télé
pour leur annoncer que j’avais
inventé un nouveau métier.
J’ai envoyé trois ou quatre lettres,
je crois,
et quelques jours plus tard,
j’ai eu une réponse de France 3
et à ma grande surprise, ils m’ont
proposé de faire un reportage.
Et deux jours [plus tard], je passais
au JT dans une petite chronique
qu’ils avaient mise en place,
qui était nouvelle.
Ça s’appelait « Coup de pouce » et pour
moi, ça a été un véritable coup de pouce
parce que suite à ce passage au JT,
j’ai eu d’autres émissions.
On m’a contacté plusieurs fois,
il y a eu des articles dans la presse,
j’ai même été à la Une du Parisien.
Mais ce qui a vraiment tout changé,
c’est une émission à la radio.
C’était Europe1.
Laurent Cabrol m’a appelé
pour m’inviter sur l’émission
parce qu’il voulait que j’explique en quoi
ça consistait, des chefs à domicile.
J’ai bien sûr accepté l’invitation.
Il faut savoir qu’à l’époque,
Laurent Cabrol présentait
une émission de téléachat.
Il a très bien présenté mon concept,
c’était très clair.
J’étais ravi.
Au moment de terminer,
malheureusement, il s’est trompé,
il a donné un mauvais numéro.
Et pour se rattraper,
il a donné mon numéro,
et il l’a répété plusieurs fois.
Ça a été encore
une meilleure chose au final.
Je rentre tranquillement chez moi,
et surprise, je découvre que
mon téléphone était saturé de messages.
Mon passage dans l’émission avait
suscité énormément d’appels.
Suite à ça, j’ai eu encore des contacts
pendant plus de deux ans ;
ça avait vraiment lancé mon activité.
Une dame m’a raconté qu’elle était
dans son bain au moment de l’émission
et pour noter mon numéro,
elle a vite pris son rouge à lèvres
et l’a écrit sur son miroir.
Suite à cette médiatisation qui était
plutôt inespérée et très inattendue,
on est venu me chercher il y a six ans.
C’est là que tout a commencé :
on m’a proposé la mission de créer
des recettes à base d’insectes.
J’ai trouvé ça très bizarre,
j’avais même beaucoup d’a priori,
j’ai failli refuser.
Finalement, je me suis dit :
« C’est un bon challenge, pourquoi pas ? »
C’est vrai que quand on parle d’insectes,
on imagine quoi ?
On pense paludisme
ou transmission de maladies.
On pense à l’Afrique qui est envahie par
les criquets, qui détruisent les récoltes.
On pense aux araignées dans nos maisons.
Pire encore, on pense
aux émissions à la télé
où des candidats sont obligés de manger
des insectes énormes et vivants -
même moi, je ne pourrais pas les manger -
tout ça pour remporter une épreuve.
Tout ça fait que,
les insectes, ce n’est pas encore
vraiment reconnu comme un aliment.
Quand on pense « insectes », on pense :
« Ça rampe, ça grouille,
ça nous dégoûte. »
Pourtant, ce n’est pas du tout nouveau,
ce n’est pas un concept venant d’arriver,
ça existe depuis bien longtemps
dans plein de pays.
Le pays où on en mange le plus,
c’est en Amérique latine, au Mexique.
Rien qu’au Mexique,
il y a 549 espèces d’insectes comestibles.
Mais il y a aussi les pays d’Asie,
Laos, Cambodge, Vietnam :
on en consomme 310 espèces différentes.
Également en Afrique,
mais que dans certaines zones.
Il y a quand même
250 espèces comestibles en Afrique.
C’est pendant la saison des pluies
qu’on consomme le plus d’insectes :
il y a des problèmes
pour s’approvisionner en protéines
et c’est donc la seule
manière de survivre.
En [Europe], contrairement
à ce qu’on imagine,
il y a uniquement quatre insectes
comestibles ; c’est très peu.
On ne comptabilise que ceux
qui sont élevés, bien sûr,
on ne va pas les prélever dans la nature.
Pourquoi a-t-on si peu d’insectes
et pourquoi les connaît-on si peu ?
En fait, c’est parce qu’on a la chance
d’avoir un climat très tempéré,
marqué par des saisons, qui fait
qu’on a une agriculture fabuleuse,
de qualité, riche.
L’idée n’est pas
de ne plus manger de viande,
c’est au contraire de dire que les
insectes peuvent être un nouvel aliment.
Pour moi, quand je cuisine,
c’est comme un nouvel ingrédient
que j’intègre à mes recettes.
Imaginez un peintre qui aurait
une nouvelle [couleur] sur sa palette
pour composer son tableau.
Ce qui me complique
encore plus les choses.
Il faut dire qu'au niveau européen, la
législation a du mal à se mettre en place.
Encore aujourd’hui, il y a peu d’insectes
qui sont autorisés par la loi.
Tout a commencé en 2010 par un rapport de
la FAO, la Food Agriculture Organization.
Dans ce rapport, il était dit que les pays
européens pouvaient venir en aide
pour résoudre les problèmes de ressources
alimentaires et écologiques de notre ère.
L’Europe a entendu le message,
mais seulement en 2018.
Ça a été long à arriver malheureusement.
En 2018, une réglementation
s’est mise en place.
Il fallait une autorisation
pour pouvoir élever des insectes,
les commercialiser et les consommer.
À partir de ce moment-là,
c’était beaucoup plus difficile
de faire des choses
parce qu’il y avait une interdiction.
Il a fallu attendre le 4 mai 2021
pour qu’enfin l’Europe autorise
un insecte, le ver de farine.
Ça a ouvert la porte à de l’espoir.
Quelques mois plus tard,
le 1er novembre 2021,
le criquet a été autorisé à son tour.
Mais les grillons qui sont élevés
en France et les vers buffalo
restent interdits encore aujourd’hui.
On attend que la loi évolue dans ce sens.
Pourtant, en France, on est des pionniers
parce que c’est le pays en Europe
où on en produit le plus.
Malheureusement, on ne les consomme pas.
Mais il y a d’autres fermes
qui se sont créées récemment aussi.
Il y a un élan.
Mais ce qu’il se passe, c’est que le peu
qu’on produit part dans les pays voisins,
en Belgique et aux Pays-Bas,
où la population est un peu plus adepte
que nous des insectes pour le moment.
Le problème de la rareté,
pour l’instant, des insectes
fait que le prix reste très élevé.
Ça ajoute un frein
au fait qu’on ne mange pas encore
beaucoup d’insectes.
Pourtant, des insectes, on en mange
sans le savoir tous les jours.
Tout le monde en a mangé,
peut-être ce matin,
parce que des insectes, on en trouve
dans les purées de fruits,
les compotes, les jus de fruits,
dans les pizzas par les coulis de tomate
et les champignons qu’on pose dessus.
Et, encore plus étonnant,
dans les brocolis surgelés.
Parce qu’il faut savoir que les brocolis
sont récoltés sur les lieux de production.
En quelques heures à peine,
ils ont été lavés et emballés,
et du coup, les insectes sont
emprisonnés dans le process.
Quand vous mangez un brocoli,
vous avez des petits fragments d’insectes.
On ignore beaucoup de choses
sur les insectes en général,
et ça, c'est aussi un frein.
Par exemple, saviez-vous que
sauterelles et criquets
font partie de la même famille que
les crevettes que vous mangez tous.
Ce sont les arthropodes.
Moi, je m'amuse des fois à cuisiner
des sauterelles en bisque.
Et on retrouve exactement
le même goût que le homard.
Ça prouve que c’est la même famille.
Pourquoi on ne mangerait pas
des insectes ?
Les insectes, c’est fabuleux
à tout point de vue :
au niveau environnemental
et au niveau nutritif.
Mais pourtant, on n’en mange pas encore.
Fabuleux au niveau environnemental,
parce qu’avec dix kilos de nourriture,
on obtient neuf kilos d’insectes,
alors qu’avec le bœuf, on n’obtient
qu’un kilo pour la même quantité.
Pour élever des insectes,
on a besoin de beaucoup moins
d’énergie, d’espace et de temps,
ils mangent très peu,
et [on a] quasiment pas besoin d’eau.
Tout ça fait que c’est très intéressant.
L’impact est beaucoup moindre.
La pollution est diminuée de 99%
par rapport à l’élevage classique
et il y a 80 % moins
d’émanations de méthane
que malheureusement
dans les élevages de bovins.
Le côté nutritif, c’est fabuleux
parce que cinq criquets,
ça équivaut à un steak haché.
Ça apporte beaucoup de protéines,
beaucoup d’acides aminés, mais pas que,
parce qu’il y a aussi
tous les autres nutriments.
On y trouve quasiment
toutes les vitamines.
Oméga trois, oméga six,
tous les minéraux,
tout ce dont le corps a besoin,
on le trouve dans les insectes.
C’est vraiment un aliment fabuleux,
pour les sportifs, mais pas que,
pour tout le monde en fait.
C’est là que mon histoire a démarré.
J’ai ouvert ma boutique il y a cinq ans,
et quelque temps plus tard,
j’ai ouvert mon restaurant.
Mon côté ambitieux et audacieux
m’a fait contacter encore
les médias à ce moment-là.
Cette fois, ce n’était pas
des courriers mais des mails.
J’ai envoyé des mails
à des chaînes de télé.
France 2 m’a contacté tout de suite,
j’ai eu un passage au JT très rapidement.
Ça m’a permis de faire connaître
ma boutique et mon restaurant.
Il y a trois jours, Arte m’a contacté
pour faire un sujet sur les insectes,
pour suivre mon parcours,
pour faire découvrir les insectes.
C’est fabuleux car
c’est ce que je recherche :
je veux qu’on en sache davantage
sur ce monde inconnu des insectes.
Mon restaurant, c’est une manière
de faire découvrir de la meilleure façon,
à travers ma cuisine, les insectes.
Dans les médias, on en parle beaucoup,
de plus en plus.
Vous avez dû entendre parler
de start-ups qui se développent,
qui ont levé des fonds pour faire des
grandes fermes, pour faire des élevages.
On voit aussi naître de nouveaux produits.
J’ai entendu parler de food trucks
voulant faire des burgers aux insectes.
On parle même de food tech.
Tout ça pour dire qu’il y a
beaucoup de produits,
beaucoup de projets, qui
pourraient se créer autour de ça -
il y a vraiment tout à inventer.
Il y a 1 500 espèces comestibles,
donc autant de produits
qu’on pourrait inventer,
lyophilisés, en poudre,
incorporés à d’autres ingrédients.
Les produits, il en existe déjà,
j’en vends dans ma boutique.
On vend des insectes aromatisés,
on vend des crackers pour découvrir
gentiment avec des amis autour d’un verre.
Il y a d’autres produits : des pâtes,
des barres protéinées pour les sportifs
pour faire un apport après l’effort,
on a même des bières
et des chocolats à base d’insectes.
Pourquoi les insectes ne sont-ils toujours
pas dans nos assiettes aujourd’hui ?
Je crois que j’ai trouvé la raison :
peu de gens sont encore
très bien informés sur le sujet.
Il y a encore beaucoup d’a priori.
C’est la raison pour laquelle
j’ai décidé d’ouvrir mon restaurant.
Je pense que c’est la meilleure façon
d’inciter les gens à essayer
dans un beau plat
bien présenté, esthétique.
Je le vois aussi dans ma boutique.
Quand ils ont voyagé et qu’ils ont
déjà eu l’occasion d’en goûter,
[les gens] sont beaucoup plus réceptifs
et goûtent beaucoup plus facilement.
Comme quoi c’est vraiment
une question d’éducation.
Dans ma cuisine, je me fais plaisir.
Je fais des plats incroyables qui font
oublier qu’on mange des insectes.
Par exemple, mon plat signature,
c’est un sablé aux grillons.
C’est une pâte sablée,
je fais comme une tartelette garnie
avec du houmous à la pomme
et je compose ma tartelette
avec des fruits, des légumes,
des fleurs, des pousses
et, bien sûr, des insectes,
tout ce qu’on retrouve
dans un jardin en fait.
Les insectes sont bien visibles,
mais sont cachés en même temps
parce qu’il y a quand même des gens
qui viennent pour l’expérience
et qui veulent en avoir pour leur argent
et voir les insectes.
Tout le monde est content avec ce plat-là.
Ma cuisine, qui est audacieuse,
qui me correspond,
est aussi une manière
de passer des messages.
Le choix de nos aliments,
le choix de la manière de nous alimenter,
ça joue sur notre santé,
et ça joue aussi sur la santé
de notre belle planète.
C’est très important.
J’ai un autre exemple.
Je fais aussi un cookie
aux vers de farine soufflé.
J’ai changé la recette : j’ai énormément
diminué la quantité de beurre,
je l’ai remplacé par de la patate douce,
ce qui permet aussi de diminuer le sucre.
J’ai donc un cookie qui est très nutritif,
qui reste gourmand.
Un client qui en a mangé récemment
a même oublié qu’il y avait des insectes,
qui sont pourtant très visibles.
La gourmandise !
Avec l’ouverture de mon restaurant
Inoveat, je me retrouve précurseur.
Fidèle à mes convictions, je veux faire
une cuisine écologique, saine, locale.
En plus, je montre que les insectes,
ça peut être une manière
d’accompagner l’explosion démographique
qui est un problème de notre époque.
Ça m’énerve et ça me scandalise
de voir qu’on a la solution
mais qu’on n’utilise pas encore
assez les insectes
pour lutter contre les problèmes de la
malnutrition et de la faim dans le monde.
La solution, c’est vous qui l’avez.
Si on se met tous à manger des insectes,
tout le monde va changer de mentalité
et le tour est joué.
On aura fait évoluer les choses.
Je compte sur vous, c’est maintenant
qu’il faut qu’on change les choses.
On va y arriver, c’est sûr.
La solution est là.
Merci de m’avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)